hallo mein name ist kuka und wir spielen
heute mal wieder geld ich habe gesehen
dass ich das ganze tatsächlich schon so
lange was ist was machen die da ich
wünsche wieder weg ich habe gesehen dass
das ganze schon irgendwie zwei wochen
also nicht mehr hochgeladen habe ich
mich nach zwei wochen ohne kevin
eigentlich eine ganze erholsame zeit
gewesen wir haben ja in den letzten von
diese ist hier denn schon wieder eine
ziege rechnet sie gelassen
wir haben ja schon mal einer folge
herausgefunden dass wenn ich in diesem
turm darum gehe dass ich dann zu
wir haben ja schon mal nachfolge
herausgekommen dass wir nicht in diesem
turm da rein gehe dass ich dann zu was
was war da noch mal ich glaube ich die
gottes siege oder so dann haben wir
herausgefunden dass da hinten irgendwo
in den bergen ist soll ufo platz da
wurde ich dann letztendlich sonne die
will devil böse ziegel im internet
geschaut dass es da sonst noch so gibt
und zwar kann man hier in das haus
reingehen und hier ist ein
wir können dieses ding mit nein
kevin nicht den farbeimer dieses dinge
können wir mit der zunge und dann können
wir das wunderschön hier hinten gleich
auf einen platz
ein jogger guck mal keinen job mehr das
können wir jetzt da hinten irgendwo auf
einem platz müssen wir das drauflegen
und dann haltet euch fest
wir haben nämlich hier schon einmal dass
wir vorne drauf und da vorne nämlich ist
es noch nicht drauf bevor ich das
allerdings mache muss das fliegt er
total komisch und bevor ich das
allerdings mache muss ich euch jetzt
zwei sagen ganz gut sagen erstes sich
sehr so völlig außer acht uhr morgens
ist und ich muss gleich wohin fahren
deswegen steht ja auch keiner weil die
alufolie und wieder lassen alle noch am
kennen die zweite sache ich bin bei typ
2 dabei falls die ps2 nicht kennt ich
habe das gestern in meiner snapshot
story erklärt das zeige ich euch mal
eben ein an alle die technisch kann es
ist eine von youtube an animierte serie
mit youtube drin und ihr könnt immer am
ende der folge bauten wer von den zehn
youtuber in der folge in der nächsten
folge noch dabei sein soll und darin
unter anderem ich dabei dann auch melina
da die hände auf platt und noch ein paar
andresen alle dabei ich werde dort als
komplett voll spaß tages ist aber
eigentlich recht witzig sogar unter
kommt hat unter anderem auch hier kevin
kommt darin vor da kann ich euch jetzt
mal ein zwei szenen einblenden
also ich packe dieses ding hier drauf
und parade
die wenigsten space ich habe keine
ahnung was ich jetzt machen kann
ich kann mich nicht mal vor und
zurückbewegen wow ich habe einfach mal
die order ist ein typ das anti blockier
bleibt hier bleib hier bleibt ihr bleibt
ihr blick hier bleib ich habe wirklich
einfach mal in den kommentaren geschaut
was ist noch so viel cooler easter eggs
in dem spiel in sachen die ich machen
kann dann kommt sowas
ich kann hier nichts machen ich weiß ja
nicht mal wie ich zurückkommen soll
diese ziegel kann nichts ich bin im
weltraum
ja ich bin im weltraum es gab überall
einen weg zurück sei es wenn ich aus dem
map geflogen weil sich ein diesel
man muss einfach nur sagen dann willst
du rücke man ist wieder zurück ich bin
wäre es nicht mal mega witzig wenn ich
nicht von diesem lkw da in slow motion
befahren lassen würde was ich hoffe ich
krieg das jetzt hinsah springs
kevin comeback liebt mich freunde
hiermit haben wir nun definitiv dem
moment erreicht wollen wir wieder sage
hey das video ist für dumme leute
geeignet nichts gegen euch aber wieso
guckt ihr euch das sonst an das macht
doch auch jetzt hier das wenn euch das
video genauso gefallen hat wie diesen
beiden tanzen den leuten hier dann zeigt
es nur mit einer bewertung zur passion
in der beschreibung merchandise in der
beschreibung ich dummkopf das kommt es
in zehn tagen raus und dann den wir uns
im nächsten video wieder wenn die da
heißt kevin reck
ok